casi dos semanas después de que las
palabras del presidente emmanuel mccomb
en defensa de la libertad la posibilidad
de hacer caricaturas del profeta mahoma
causarán furia en el mundo musulmán el
presidente de indonesia el país con la
mayor población musulmana del mundo
envía un mensaje de calma aunque condenó
los comentarios del mandatario francés
en un ayamonte
sampras indonesia condena la violencia
en parís y niza que ha cobrado vidas
sin embargo indonesia también condena
fuertemente las declaraciones del
presidente francés porque ha insultado
al islam hiriendo los sentimientos de
los musulmanes alrededor del mundo y
podría dividir la unidad de los
creyentes están bis logros unía el 21 de
octubre durante el homenaje nacional a
samuel para ti el profesor que fue
asesinado por mostrar imágenes del
profeta mahoma en su clase el presidente
francés hizo declaraciones con respecto
al derecho a las caricaturas
desde entonces ha habido docenas de
manifestaciones en contra de francia
llamados a no comprar productos de la
nación europea
mccomb extendió su mensaje su cupo el
respecto pista yo entiendo y respeto la
ira de las personas con respecto a las
caricaturas nunca aceptaré la
justificación de la violencia física por
estas caricaturas de fondo mente y
siempre defenderé la libertad de hablar
escribir pensar y dibujar en mi país
desde cine otras figuras del gobierno
francés han intentado también ponerle
fin a la controversia
sin embargo macon sigue siendo impopular
gran parte del mundo musulmán
[Música]